we now have active pilot projects
testing the ability to provide what we
call econ sults or virtual consoles
electronically to providers all over the
country primary care providers we
believe that the initial effort should
be not directly to patients but to
patients through their primary care
provider because we think that patients
ultimately going to need a continuous
relationship with a team of providers in
their own community that's a second
initiative that we have it's something
called the advanced medical home where
we're organizing teams of providers to
maintain a continuous relationship with
patients within their community a third
initiative that gets to the genetic
profiling is we're trying to understand
through designer centered research when
patients and now and and now this is
available commercially there are three
companies out there that will provide
you with a genetic analysis if you
provide them with a biological specimen
whether it's a blood sample or a spit
sample or a hair sample and we're trying
to find out well what a patient's expect
when they do this and when they get the
information that says they have based on
your genetic profile forty percent
increased chance of getting type 2
diabetes or a three-fold increase in the
chance of getting Alzheimer's disease
how do they understand that how does
that affect the way they think about
their health what is it what what do
they do with that information what do
the primary care providers that they may
go to with that information how do they
understand it how does this affect their
ability to modify their lifestyle and
and so that would be that would be a
third concrete project that we're
wearing